bonjour nous sommes en direct
aujourd'hui pour vous faire un nouveau
point de situation sur ce qu'il se passe
en Ukraine lors de cette guerre qui
continue et aujourd'hui nous sommes une
nouvelle fois avec Alexis firschak
bonjour Alexis bonjour Vincent
journaliste et adjoint Opel actu avec
vous on va revenir sur ces cartes qu'on
diffuse depuis le début de ce conflit
vous les voyez c'est celle-ci ces cartes
déjà Alexis est-ce qu'on peut parler de
d'un point de vue général comment évolue
le conflit alors d'un point de vue
général la principale actualité de
aujourd'hui en réalité depuis pas mal de
semaines maintenant c'est ce qui se
passe tout à l'ouest du dispositif russe
dans la région de Kerson sur la rive
droite du fleuve niapra on va en
reparler c'est là où les il y a une
contre-offensive
ukrainienne qui dure en réalité depuis
le mois de septembre les
Ukrainiens ont avancé on le voit ils ont
grignoté par le nord on le voit un peu
moins bien mais ils sont aussi grignotés
un peu par l'Ouest
et
les lignes de front c'était stabilisée
néanmoins mais on va voir les Russes
c'était dans une position
insoluble et donc là depuis plusieurs
semaines on parlait d'un éventuel
retrait russe et le retrait russe a été
annoncé hier officiellement alors
maintenant on va voir ça peut prendre du
temps et il faut aussi parler de toutes
les implications et voilà mais disons le
principal c'est une défaite de portée
stratégique pour pour Vladimir Poutine
effectivement et pour pas les rapidement
on va on va s'attarder sur sur certaines
juste après mais dans le reste du pays
la situation n'évolue pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup alors si vous voulez ce qui est
il y a deux choses on va couper la carte
en 3 vous voyez la zone au nord la zone
avec le bleu c'est là dans la région de
le long de la région de kerkiff
c'est là où il y avait eu la
contre-offensive ukrainienne au mois de
septembre qui pour le coup avait été
extrêmement rapide c'est tous les
territoires que les Ukrainiens ont
repris en bleu vous voyez que la ligne
de front s'est arrêtée le long de la
frontière entre l'aublas de carquif et
le blast de l'ougance le quasiment à 95%
contrôlé encore par la Russie ça fait
partie des quatre oblates des cas de
régions que la que la Russie a annexé
formellement et là la ligne de front qui
suit la frontière entre ces deux régions
elle est à peu près stable depuis
plusieurs semaines je dis bien à peu
près parce qu'en réalité les Ukrainiens
continuent de pousser et grignote
toujours un peu de territoire je pense
qu'on en reparlera brièvement si ensuite
on descend au sud c'est plus le Blas de
Lugan c'est celui de doniak et là c'est
le seul endroit où les russes continuent
à pousser je dis pas qu'ils avancent
enfin ils avancent mais mais avec une
lenteur qui est si vous voulez l'échelle
des conflits on parle plus de de
dynamique qui qui en dizaine de
kilomètres ou même en kilomètres là la
dynamique c'est parfois quelques mètres
chaque jour c'est même pas quelques rues
c'est parfois quelques numéros de rue
c'est vraiment de la bataille urbaine
les Russes poussent avec de l'artillerie
ils ont un manque d'infoncerie en
reparlera aussi et ils ont énormément de
mal à avancer notamment dans une ville
qui est très importante qu'il avait de
backgrout donc qui est dans le blaze de
doniak et pareil les Russes ont annexé
l'intégralité de cette aulaste lorsqu'on
ce que l'on voit là sur la carte c'est
qu'il ne contrôle grosso modo que la
moitié de cette blast l'autre moitié est
toujours tenu par les ukrainiens et
notamment la grande ville de Kramatorsk
qui est la capitale
ukrainienne maintenant du donielsk et
une ville à côté qui s'appelle
et la ligne de front en réalité d'un
point qu'on voit la carte macroscopique
on a l'impression qu'elle ne bouge pas
il faut zoomer vraiment à très très
grande échelle pour pour voir si on voit
les mouvements microscopiques et le
front de du Sud qu'on va appeler
zapporigia donc qui est le troisième
blast qui a été annexé par la Russie lui
il est relativement stable depuis pas
mal de semaines là encore
mais on verra qu'il est très stratégique
parce que c'est cette blaste là qui
permet de relier le don basse le Dombas
c'est à l'Est formé de l'ougance qui est
de Denis qui permet de de
passer du denisque à le Blas de Carson
oui dont on parle aujourd'hui
et le Blas de de Carson lui-même donne
ensuite sur la Crimée donc en fait si
vous voulez l'enjeu stratégique pour
pour la Russie c'est de maintenir à tout
une continuité territoriale entre la
Crimée qui a été annexée en 2014 et les
territoires de on va dire de l'ancienne
en Russie puisque maintenant la Russie
prétend avoir
agrandi son territoire national et donc
en passant par ces quatre Oblats annexés
qui forment une sorte de corridor
terrestre le long de la mère d'Azov
effectivement alors on va ça du Florian
Richard qui nous a rejoint vous
n'hésitez pas tout au long de ce soleil
bien sûr à poser vos questions on
essayait d'y répondre toujours on va
s'attarder maintenant à ce qui se passe
du côté de Carson donc là en fait alors
pour que je vous montre un peu plus
précisément ce qui se passe on va aller
dans cette zone ici qui est absolument
qui est là et on va zoomer dedans via
cette nouvelle carte fait par le service
infographie du Figaro qu'on remercie
d'ailleurs pour son travail sur ce
conflit qui nous permet de mieux voir ce
qui s'y passe voilà et en fait on voit
donc que c'est l'endroit où
ou les Ukrainiens avancent beaucoup
absolument alors beaucoup avancé malgré
tout pas aussi rapidement que par
exemple dans la région de de l'ougance
en septembre pourquoi parce que les
Russes depuis cette offensive qui a
commencé je vous dis on va dire fin août
les Russes résistaient à Carson
là tout semble indiquer que les Russes
ont fait le choix d'abandonner la rive
droite du Nieppe il faut vraiment faut
parler géographie la cette région de de
Carson qui a été annexée par la Russie
elle est traversée par le niep qui a un
très très grand fleuve là on se rend pas
compte parce qu'on a l'impression que
vers la mer Noire c'est tout fin mais en
réalité non c'est ce que ce qui en amont
c'est absolument c'est une largeur je
pense qu'il y a 10 km le point le plus
le plus faible là où le nie après le
plus étroit il déjà largement un
kilomètre d'accord donc si vous voulez
il faut se dire que le nièpre forme une
frontière naturelle si on le voit dans
la guerre en Ukraine depuis maintenant
plus de 8 mois on retrouve les cours
d'eau vraiment comme des frontières
naturelles et le Nieppe particulièrement
et donc si vous voulez les Russes
au départ ils avaient avancé de l'autre
côté en venant de la Crimée ils avaient
avancé ils avaient franchi le niapre il
y a pas énormément de points de passage
il y a un grand pont à Carson qui
s'appelle le pont antonetzky et puis
vous voyez là-haut là où le le niep se
rétrécit en fait c'est le barrage
hydroélectrique de Novak akovka on va en
parler qui est très important donc si il
y a peu de points de passage les Russes
avaient créé une tête de pont sur le
Nieppe mais avec une idée c'était pas
juste de s'arrêter juste derrière à ce
moment-là il voulait avancer il voulait
avancer probablement dans la palacer
mais probablement pour aller jusqu'àoder
ça c'était bien
privé l'Ukraine d'un accès à la mer et
contrôler l'intégralité des bords de la
de la mer Noire on sait que ça c'est
terminé donc maintenant il se retrouve
avec une tête de pont extrêmement
étroite qui d'un point de vue militaire
n'a pas très grand sens parce qu'en
revanche défendre une tête de Ponce
c'est extrêmement coûteux pourquoi parce
que l'artillerie
ukrainienne n'a eu de cesse depuis des
mois de pilonner justement les 10 ponts
pas les 10 les dépôts et donc si vous
voulez les les Russes ont énormément de
mal à ravitailler le contingent russe
qui se trouve sur la rive droite en
termes de logistique c'est extrêmement
compliqué les Ukrainiens ont bénéficié
des armes américaines notamment des
canaux imars qu'on ne portait de 80 km
et une précision de l'ordre du maître
et donc les rôles c'était dans une
position absolue on estime que il y a en
tout cas il y a quelques jours ou
quelques semaines il y avait entre 15 et
30 000 soldats russes sur la rive droite
du Nièvre et ce qui est
un dispositif très important il y avait
au moins de l'autre côté deux fois plus
du craignant là on sait que l'avantage
et à la défense donc les Russes malgré
tout arriver à peu près à tenir mais un
prix exorbitant et donc ce qu'on a vu
mais ça c'est ça c'est fait sur
plusieurs semaines
il y a eu les annonces d'abord
d'évacuation des civils de Carson les
Russes ont évacuées probablement 110 000
personnes deux personnes de la ville de
Carson de l'autre côté du Nièvre voyez
enfin dans la région de sur la rive
gauche et par ailleurs ensuite on a vu
que certains matériels lourds russes
étaient étaient pareil transbordés de
l'autre côté d'une Nièvre alors pour ça
c'est très compliqué compliqué le pont
antonelle ce qui est très difficilement
praticable il y a des ponts flottants
mais qui sont régulièrement détruits par
les Ukrainiens on peut passer à Novak
kakova mais quelquefois mais là encore
avec des difficultés sinon il y a une
sorte de système de petits ferry avec
des petits bateaux enfin tout ça c'est
une logique une logistique monstrueuse
et donc les Russes si vous voulez en
commencer par faire partir l'état-major
les centres de commandement le matériel
lourd ils ont installé l'artillerie sur
la rive gauche du Nieppe qui servira à
bombarder de l'autre côté et maintenant
la question c'est comment ils arrivent à
se replier
en bonne ordre et sans perdre ce
contingent qui est encore important
sachant que le risque évidemment c'est
qu'il se replie
avec une attaque sur leurs arrières
désukrainiens oui et du coup et donc ça
pourrait être terrible les Russes
peuvent perdre
énormément de trous alors à l'origine
c'était en plus d'excellentes qui
étaient là-bas notamment des troupes
aéroportées les VVV il semblerait je
disais au conditionnel parce que on a
parfois peu d'informations dans cette
guerre il semblerait que
il y a eu un redéploiement donc les
meilleurs troupes est déjà été
exfiltrer entre guillemets elles ont été
remplacées par des troubles justement de
mobiliser puisque entre temps après la
grande offensive
ukrainienne dans le dans la région de de
lougan vous souvenez que les Russes face
à cet échec militaire il faut quand même
bien appeler ça un échec très lourd les
Russes ont été obligés de lancer une
mobilisation partielle qui alterne
portera sur 330 000 hommes et
aujourd'hui à peu près 80 000 hommes
mobilisés qui sont déjà déployés sur
et donc une partie qui le sont ici à
Carson maintenant ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que cette se replie
russe qui est encore une fois je le
répète est une défaite même si les
rationnels militairement
se repli ne va pas se faire en 24 heures
on parle plusieurs jours voir une
semaine deux semaines je on a évidemment
on n'a pas la réponse mais si vous
voulez
faire se replier 15000 hommes avec le
matériel qui va avec les munitions etc
c'est un travail considérable surtout si
les Ukrainiens derrière font pression
sur les Russes alors les Ukrainiens eux
sont extrêmement méfiants
et estime qui pourrait y avoir un piège
parce que on imagine que si ils sont de
l'autre côté de la rive ils peuvent
arriver à Carson et se faire bombarder
une fois qu'ils sont oui
oui alors après il y a quand même peu
d'experts militaires qui aujourd'hui
croient à cette thèse du piège c'est à
dire attirer les Ukrainiens vers Carson
pour les bombardés pour les entraîner
dans un combat de
urbain qui est toujours à la défaveur de
de l'attaquant
il y a quand même peu d'experts qui y
croient mais si vous voulez il y a une
temporalité
qui est longue et qui fait que pour les
Ukrainiens à mon avis c'est difficile de
savoir quand est-ce à quel rythme ils
doivent avancer pour reprendre
l'intégralité de la rive droite du
diable je pense que la question est
plutôt là par ailleurs y a-t-il des
négociations on en parlera tout à
l'heure mais tout indique qu'il y a que
ce soit les occidentaux les Russes les
Ukrainiens les Russes il y a des
contacts beaucoup plus il y a quelques
semaines et puis par ailleurs il y a une
inconnue c'est le fameux barrage de
novaka oui parce que ça on parlait tout
à l'heure de bombardements sur les ponts
les Ukrainiens peuvent pas se permettre
de bombarder un barrage
alors russe et ukrainien c'est que
mutuellement de l'avoir bombardé
il est probable que les deux un peu
raison voilà
comme mon souvenir avec la centrale oui
effectivement c'est la même chose ce qui
est sûr c'est que au début quand on
disait que les Russes voulaient rester à
tout prix à Carson parce que c'était
extrêmement important parce que c'est la
seule capitale régionale qui disait
conquis depuis le 24 février parce que
c'est une tête de pont extrêmement
stratégique sur le niep là on pouvait se
dire les Russes n'ont aucun intérêt à
bombarder à faire s'effondrer le barrage
Inno électrique parce que derrière vous
avez une quantité d'eau absolument
considérable qui est en gros
ça pourrait engloutir il y a eu des
estimations mais ce serait plusieurs
mètres d'eau dans la ville partie de
Carson pendant plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines donc on se disait dans ce
scénario là les Russes n'ont aucun
intérêt à saboter le le barrage d'une
roue électrique et à le faire sauter
maintenant on est dans une
position différente puisque les Russes
visiblement ont quand même pris la
décision complètement forcée par les
événements militaires mais enfin il
semble décider aujourd'hui
à se retirer sur le drive dès lors
ont-ils intérêt à laisser le barrage qui
peut servir
aux Ukrainiens à passer c'est pas
évident on en est en tout cas on en est
pas là on en est pas au point où on peut
dire les Russes vont faire sauter le
barrage mais c'est évident que cette
question du barrage de Novak lakovka
fait partie du rapport de force des
éventuelles négociations
il y a quand même un élément c'est que
vous voyez le barrage de novaka donc il
fait monter le niveau d'une Nièvre c'est
à partir de là que par le canal de
Crimée qui comme son nom l'indique relie
le niep à la Crimée et c'est ce canal
qui ensuite permet à la Crimée d'avoir
de l'eau on sait que la c'est un caillou
la gamine des manque d'eau considérable
et donc si le barrage est cassé le
niveau du Nieppe à cet en amont descend
subitement et il est pas sûr que les le
canal sera improvisé en eau et donc il y
aura des pénuries redos en Crimée donc
pour les Russes c'est quand même il y a
des enjeux stratégiques
et tout ça pour vous dire que voilà il
faut pas se dire que les Russes ont
replier dans la journée
c'est un processus qui peut prendre des
jours voir une semaine de semaine
peut-être trois semaines oui parce que
là même si on dit que ça a beaucoup
avancé c'est aussi une affaire de
semaine c'est flèches qu'on voit ici
toute la zone en bleu si vous voulez pas
non plus gigantesque en surface ça a été
repris de depuis le début du mois de
septembre donc ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'avancée
ukrainienne dans la région de lougans où
il y avait 10 000 kilomètres carrés
voire plus qui avait été repris en
quelques jours on rappelle cette zone
bleue on voit bien la différence c'est
pas du tout on parle de petits points
bleus qui sont ici en fait
et puis le Nord oui effectivement
mais si vous voulez en termes de
superficie c'est pas du tout la même
chose mais pourquoi parce que à
l'ougance donc la grande zone bleue
enfin un truc art qui fait lougans les
Russes c'était replié il n'était pas
allé au contact en revanche il se met au
contact et il résiste
justement la frontière entre carquif et
Lougansk depuis maintenant à peu près un
mois et on voit que depuis que les rues
de résistent
ils ont du mal ils ont énormément de mal
et d'ailleurs il recule un tout petit
peu mais quand même il parviennent à peu
près dans l'instant
à juguler cette contrefensive Ukraine
alors on va parler un peu des de ce qui
se pourrait se passer ensuite si la
ville de Carson est reprise ce qui est
semble être en chemin même si on va bien
sûr rester prudent par rapport à ça on a
une question qui nous dit est-ce que
c'est un début de reconquête vers la
Crimée
alors personnellement je pense pas pour
une raison simple c'est qu'il faudrait
que donc les rues se replient ils sont
de l'autre côté du niepre et ensuite
donc ils ont une frontière naturelle qui
les protège
les Ukrainiens auront énormément de mal
à créer une tête de pont à cet endroit
là d'accord donc en fait ça
en train de dire que c'est pas un
objectif stratégique des Ukrainiens à
l'horizon de quelques mois je dis
simplement qu'à court terme je vois pas
tellement comment les Ukrainiens vont
pouvoir quand on regarde de loin
évidemment on a l'impression que c'est
un accès direct avec 30 km de la Crimée
on peut dire que c'est très franchement
je pense que les Ukrainiens auront du
mal à passer le nid après puis même si
on parle souvent de d'attaque de
commandant ça c'est la Russe notamment
qui voit des attaques de commando par
bateau tout le temps sur justement de
l'autre côté près de près de la centrale
nucléaire
on est à mon avis il y a beaucoup de
d'attaque qui ne sont pas vraies il y en
a peut-être certaines qui le sont mais
si vous voulez arriver à déployer un peu
d'infanterie c'est une chose et ensuite
le matériel lourd vous le faites passer
commande
donc ça serait un cauchemar en termes de
logistique donc je pense qu'on en est
pas là et c'est la raison principale
d'un point de vue militaire pour
laquelle à mon avis les Russes ont été
contraints de se replier c'est qu'ils
ont beaucoup moins de mal à tenir le
front il faut dire que le front fait
100000 fait 100 km et les Russes jusqu'à
il y a pas très longtemps on se souvient
ils avaient donc il était entré en
Ukraine avec 200 000 hommes
mais il faut pas rêver il y a des pertes
énormes alors on n'a pas les chiffres là
justement le chef d'État majeur
américain générale Millet a dit qu'il y
avait 80000 au moins 100 000 morts et
blessés du côté russe probablement au
temps du côté ukrainien
à la louche apparaît des chiffres assez
sérieux c'est à dire que l'effectif de
départ que tes russes il a été
énormément réduit je suis pas sûr que
les Russes aient pu le reconstituer
avant la mobilisation partielle et là où
il y a 80000 bon ils ont allé maximum
actuellement 200000 hommes pour tenir
1000 km de de fond en réalité c'est
considérable oui et encore une fois 200
000 hommes ça c'est le plus important on
l'avait identifié dès les premiers jours
de l'invasion russe envahit un pays
comme l'Ukraine avec 200000 hommes il y
avait quelque chose de fou d'un point de
vue stratégique alors on avait élève qui
demande du coup
qui est content de nous retrouver nous
aussi on est content de nous retrouver
ça qu'il est souvent dans les dans de
live où va se trouver la nouvelle ligne
de défense après le retrait des Russ
le long le long du Nièvre les deux
armées vont se faire face et on l'a dit
c'est pas un petit cours d'eau ah non
c'est pas un petit couteau c'est
l'endroit où il est le plus étroit c'est
à dire plutôt
vers l'embouchure il y a au moins un
kilomètre oui
très difficile de le franchir
effectivement donc voilà pour la réponse
Florian qui nous demande si les Russes
alors on n'a pas été prise le barrage
cela inondera que la rive gauche ou
est-ce que nous savons le message est
pas très bien écrit du coup je le
conseiller
le plus visiblement un peu les deux
voilà c'était un des argues enfin c'est
une des questions qu'on se posait quel
est l'intérêt des des Russes il a inondé
y compris la rive gauche là où
précisément il faudrait mettre leur
artillerie pour bombarder de l'autre
côté alors il y a luxe qui nous dit que
c'est n'importe quoi le retrait
stratégie qu'il faut être naïf aura de
défaite ou autre invention médiatique ah
non mais attendez il faut être
extrêmement clair c'est une défaite
stratégique pour petit voilà c'était
d'une part mais voilà la défaite étant
actée
il n'empêche qu'on peut malgré tout dans
la défaite essayer d'être rationnel de
limiter les pots cassés et dans ces
conditions là le moins stupide pour les
Russes c'était de tenter un repli en
donnant oui plutôt que de tenir parce
que encore une fois donc les Russes
avaient 15000 20.000 ils auraient pu
tout à fait rester à Carson et se lancer
dans une bataille urbaine parce que si
vous voulez tout autour de Carson c'est
vraiment de la steppe et on voit les
vidéos
mais c'est vraiment de la STEP donc
c'est des combats des duels d'artillerie
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
qui est très différent ça n'a rien à
voir avec une bataille urbaine Carson
c'était une ville qui avait 280 000
habitants
avant le avant le la guerre le début de
la guerre encore une fois on a vu à
Mario Paul les batailles
urbaines c'est des batailles qui peuvent
durer extrêmement longtemps qui sont
extrêmement meurtrières donc la Russie
aurait pu tenir peut-être un mois de
moins trois mois que sais-je mais pour
quel quel intérêt le la tête de pont
n'avait plus d'intérêt et le fait
qu'elle n'est plus n'est plus d'intérêt
c'est précisément la marque de la
défaite stratégique de l'admire Poutine
parce qu'en fait quel est l'intérêt
quelle était l'intérêt pour Poutine
c'était de de montrer qu'il pouvait
encore aller de l'autre côté d'une
Nièvre et peut-être un jour
percer vers l'ouest oui puisque au
dessin
on en est plus là et donc en fait avoir
cette tête de pont ça ne sert plus à
rien d'un point de vue militaire en
revanche il faut voir que la conséquence
de ce retrait politiquement ici
va être terrible pour les Russes alors
ils sont en train de bâtir tout un
propagande de guerre pour justifier ça
alors il y a il y a beaucoup la question
de protéger la vie des soldats russes
notamment ceux des mobiliser etc etc
mais je pense pas que les Russes soient
dupes la Russie a un mois un peu forcé
par la contrefensive ukrainienne a
annexé les territoires l'intégralité de
le blast de Carson bon bah aujourd'hui
il se retire de toute la partie ouest de
cette blast y compris de la capitale
régionale de cette glace
difficile à défendre une politiquement
effectivement la ville de Carson on peut
le dire aussi puisque c'était l'un c'est
quand même la grande prise de la Russie
très rapidement dans ce conflit
absolument
non non alors non pas tout à fait parce
que c'est Mario Paul oui 400000
habitants avant guerre
en fait les Russes raisons d'être précis
attention
les Russes n'ont pas pris énormément de
de grandes villes
depuis le 24 février mais encore une
fois c'est pas avec 200 000 habitants
que vous pouvez faire une chose pareille
en gros ils ont pris donc personne 280
000 habitants il y a quelques petites
villes de plus entre 100 000 et 200 000
dans l'ougance qu'ils ont pris les
échange c'est
ils ont pris quoi d'autre ils ont pris
Mario Paul donc est la plus grande ville
400 000 habitants et dans un porrigia il
y a des villes
mes modestes mélitopoles merdiences etc
paradoxalement il y en a il y a beaucoup
moins de grandes villes que lors des
opérations 2014 puisqu'en 2014 ils
avaient annexé toute la Crimée qu'avec
la ville de Sébastopol notamment et puis
ils avaient annexé la partie de du don
basse où il y avait les deux plus
grandes villes de la région l'ougansk
et donuts de donner accès notamment je
veux pas dire de bêtises mais je crois
qu'on était
c'est une des plus grandes villes de
dukraine je crois que c'est quatrième ou
la cinquième peut-être voilà c'était
vraiment considérable non d'un point de
vue
urbain la Russie a peu avancée depuis
depuis le 24 février donc la perte de
Carson politiquement est considérable on
avait élève qui nous demande à ton des
indices sur une éventuelle contrevancie
dans la région de zaporigia ça pourrait
isoler les soldats du côté de Carson de
logistique alors je sais pas de
consensus de quel côté par contre en
fait il faut avoir plusieurs choses à
l'esprit la première c'est que là on
rentre dans l'hiver
donc là déjà le fait que les contrefa
avec les mouvements et diminué
c'est aussi le signe de l'automne parce
que vous avez la boue et donc les tous
les blindés les chars ne peuvent plus
passer que par les routes par les champs
ils sont beaux donc ça réduit la
mobilité
notamment pour pour l'attaquant donc ça
ça pure ralentir les les Ukrainiens
ensuite qu'est-ce qui va se passer les
sols vont se geler avec l'hiver ils vont
durcir de nouveau sur le papier on peut
utiliser
les chars ailleurs que sur la route
malgré tout l'hiver il fait froid etc la
logistique est plus compliqué donc si
vous voulez les éléments naturels
ne sont pas très propices à une grande
contrefensive elle n'est pas du tout
impossible parce qu'encore une fois
l'hiver est bien moins pire pour la
manœuvre que l'automne ou la fin de
l'hiver et les Allemands savent quelque
chose pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
malgré tout il y a petit élément là à
prendre en compte et l'autre élément à
prendre en compte c'est que donc les
Russes vont à Carson avoir une ligne de
défense
plus facile à tenir donc ils vont
pouvoir peut-être redéployer un peu des
soldats qui étaient sur la rive Est
d'une Nièvre ils vont pouvoir les
redéployer ailleurs et puis surtout il y
a la montée en puissance des mobilisés
alors on sait qu'ils sont probablement
pas d'une excellente qualité tactique
mais malgré tout il y a un effet de
masse je vous disais tout à l'heure il y
avait à l'origine 200000 hommes on était
probablement à cause de la tradition des
forces descendues autour de 150 000 là
il y A 330 000 mobilisés qui vont
arriver dans les semaines et dans les
deux mois qui viennent oui parce que
c'est la mobilisation annoncée par la
routine qui venait du temps à arriver
c'est ça donc on passe quand même un
dispositif russe qui va probablement
être
entre 400 et 500 000 hommes en Ukraine
malgré tout cet effet de masse produira
un effet je suis vraiment pas sûr que
cet effet sera suffisant pour permettre
aux Russes de reprendre l'initiative de
relancer une offensive ça j'ai vraiment
des doutes surtout quand on voit la
qualité tactique donc ils font preuve
sur le terrain qui n'est pas gigantesque
mais malgré tout ça aura un effet au
moins pour la défensive et donc les
Ukrainiens a priori ont quand même plus
de mal à avancer à avancer d'autant que
la ligne de front va se réduire un peu
enfin elle serait du pas tellement en
taille mais c'est qu'il y a toute une
partie qui est plus difficile à plus
facile à défendre
qu'ils sont passés du Nièvre soit on le
disait depuis le début
je pense que les Ukrainiens un moment ou
un autre vont tenter une autre
contre-offensive
j'ai vraiment des doutes sur le fait
qu'il le fasse à Carson pour les raisons
qu'on a dit sur le nièpre la question
c'est est-ce que il essaie de repousser
comme ils l'ont fait à l'automne
vers l'ougance là où il y a les
territoires bleues j'essaie de continuer
doniels que c'est là que les Russes
poussent mais on peut imaginer
pourquoi pas une une contre-offensive
ukrainienne à cet endroit là pour par
exemple prendre la ville de Lizi de
chance beaucoup parlé que les Russes
avaient pris avec difficulté
et après il y a l'hypothèse qui est
souvent mentionnée d'une grande
offensive
ukrainienne dans la région de la
puricien alors il y a plusieurs raisons
déjà les Ukrainiens pourrait tenter de
reprendre la centrale de zapperidja
qu'on voit sur la carte qui est le long
du Nièvre pour le refroidissement
réacteur et puis par ailleurs ça
permettrait de couper le positif russe
en deux s'ils arrivent à aller jusqu'à
la mer d'Azov jusqu'à berdiance par
exemple
et donc justement là ça serait une des
fesses stratégiques de beaucoup plus
grand d'ampleur que Carson parce que
précisément ça ça casserait cette
continuité territoriale entre la Crimée
et
la Russie et le donbasse
enfin la Russie via le don-basse et ça
ça serait absolument terrifiant pour le
pour les Russes je suis pas sûr que le
régime de venir Poutine pourrait
pour y survivre parce que là donc c'est
une des fesses stratégiques pour Poutine
vladim Poutine peut dire regarder on a
gagné cette continuité des territoriale
ce corridor qui relie la Crimée à la
Russie c'est extrêmement mince par
rapport à par rapport au coût de la
guerre en Ukraine mais il peut toujours
dire écouter objectivement on est dans
une meilleure situation qu'a 24 février
c'est vrai
là si il perdent ce corridor
là mais ça serait une humiliation totale
pour les pour les Russes
RTF qui nous demande les USA donc
qu'en est-il du côté de l'Ukraine est-ce
qu'on a des nouvelles le général dont je
vous parlais il est donc le chef
d'état-majeur américain a estimé que les
pertes étaient les mêmes du côté
d'accord et c'était à la fin c'était pas
que les tuer
effectivement donc voilà pour la pour la
en revanche ce qui est sûr depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois et même en
réalité peut-être depuis le début
il y a une supériorité numérique
ukrainienne qui est indubitable
on n'a pas le rapport si vous voulez je
peux pas de 1 à 2 je sais rien la mais
il y a une supériorité numérique ce qui
est déjà est hallucinant quel pays enfin
en général un pays qui envahi à une
supériorité numérique sur le défenseur
puisque il y a un avantage à la défense
donc c'est très bizarre d'attaquer à
moins ce qu'il y a pour les Ukrainiens
c'est que des parts ils avaient une
masse surtout qu'ils ont mobilisé pour
le coup de mobilisation générale depuis
le début c'est une masse d'homme
considérable la question c'était plutôt
les équipements
pour armer ces hommes et ça ce n'était
rendu possible au bout de plusieurs mois
que par les fournitures d'équipements
occidentaux oui effectivement on a
beaucoup parlé et qui permettent
d'ailleurs à ce sujet et donc juste pour
conclure pour dire que dans les
prochaines semaines cet avantage
numérique des Ukrainiens qui à mon avis
fait quand même beaucoup dans les succès
récents des Ukrainiens ils vont
peut-être le père de en tout cas il va
se réduire du fait mécanique de la
mobilisation partielle des Russes oui et
puis parce que eux ils ont déjà fait
mobilisation générale donc ils ont plus
de réserves dans laquelle piocher
finalement
si parce qu'ils ont pas du tout épuisé
encore une fois le problème c'est qu'on
fait la mobilisation c'est pas tellement
de trouver les hommes ça par définition
générale on en a plusieurs millions
c'est d'avoir les équipements de former
d'organiser de gérer etc c'est ça le
plus difficile effectivement alors tout
à l'heure on parlait de de l'hiver
est-ce que du coup on peut s'attendre à
un conflit qui se gèle entre guillemets
pendant l'hiver et les choses ne bougent
pas de tout est possible dans un mois
jusqu'au jusqu'à mars puisque les
mouvements
étonné qui n'y est aucune
contre-offensive
ukrainienne ou que les Russes arrêtent
de presser
dans le dos nièce donc je pense pas
qu'il y aura un conflit gelé comme on
avait vu en 2015 après les accords de
ministre par exemple
pourquoi parce que précisément en
général quand un conflit se gèle il faut
qu'il y a un rapport de force militaire
qui le permet mais en général c'est
aussi la marque de négociation oui voilà
or pour l'instant on n'y est pas il y a
pas d'accord
il y a un frémissement qui tente à
montrer que
on commence à réévoquer la question des
négociations on en rediscute Pierre de
Villiers ancien chef des armées était
sur BFM TV hier il a dit que la guerre
en Ukraine n'était pas dans l'intérêt
des Européens certainement pas de la
France peut-être des Américains il
disait aiguiser aussi une chose c'est
que il fallait en sortir par les
négociations lui voyez il a dit quelque
chose de politiquement assez incorrect
mais qui est relativement exacte malgré
tout c'est qu'il y a une certitude c'est
que les Européens
perdent énormément dans la guerre en
Ukraine c'est pour eux si vous voulez un
dans tous les cas ils perdent énormément
et les Américains pour des raisons
évidentes géographiques notamment eux
perdent beaucoup moins oui
malgré tout
je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire que du coup
les Américains veulent continuer la
guerre à tout prix et que les Européens
ne le voudraient pas d'ailleurs on le
voit les Américains eux-mêmes
aujourd'hui sont les premiers à
commencer à dire aux Ukrainiens
on ne croit pas à une solution militaire
à une victoire militaire c'est-à-dire
que le conflit sera
résolu par la victoire de l'un ou
l'autre en l'occurrence évidemment il
pensait au ukrainien c'est une manière
de dire aux Ukrainiens
vous allez pas reprendre l'intégralité
des territoires vous n'allez pas aller
jusqu'à la Crimée et puis il y aura un
état de fait
et ça sera terminé voilà et on pourra
pas aller plus loin et en fait on se
retrouvera dans la même situation qu'en
2014 avec lacrim donc les Américains et
les Occidentaux de manière générale
disent bien que l'idée c'est d'établir
un rapport un rapport de force militaire
qui soit favorable à l'Ukraine que
l'Ukraine aille le plus loin possible
mais au bout d'un moment qu'un règlement
diplomatique du conflit et c'est une
petite musique qui monte de plus en plus
il y a eu vous avez les cette petite
minorité de républicains et une petite
minorité de de démocrate qui ont dit aux
États-Unis enfin qui ont une tenue des
positions très isolationnistes
aux États-Unis je à mon avis l'enjeu
n'est pas tellement là parce que malgré
tout il y a quand même un consensus de
la classe politique aux États-Unis pour
dire qu'il faut soutenir l'Ukraine donc
je
que tous les cas l'issue des mythermes
ça change radicalement la donne c'est à
dire que il y a un arrêt de la
fourniture d'armes aux
Ukrainiens ça je j'y crois pas trop en
revanche ce qui est vrai
c'est que pendant ces termes la
principale crainte des Ukrainiens des
Américains pardon c'était l'inflation
et par ailleurs il y a toujours
cette les Américains ont à l'esprit que
le grand danger stratégique dans les
années à venir c'est la Chine et que
généralement mauvais de mener
de guerre sur deux fronts différents
donc c'est plutôt là qu'à mon avis un
jour ou l'autre on sait pas encore
exactement comme et un jour ou l'autre
la vision américaine
de la fin de l'ayant Ukraine et la
vision ukrainienne de la fin de la
guerre en Ukraine pourrait diverger
et là ça sera intéressant de voir
comment pourrait s'enclencher
d'éventuelles négociations et donc le
général De Villiers disait cela et il
disait également
chose très intéressante que que Vladimir
Poutine en fait
à partir de quand il aura trop perdu il
aura plus rien à perdre et que du coup
il faut se garder quand même de tout
escalade trop radical parce que on ne
sait pas jusqu'où ça pourrait nous
emmener on avait parlé plein de fois du
nucléaire on va pas y revenir mais
encore une fois sur ça en plus
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
depuis le début du conflit les
Américains je vais y arriver
font quand même attention
à ne pas entretenir une escalade
qui se rapprocherait complètement à
conséquente entre Washington et Moscou
est d'ailleurs les les
Russes notamment sur la question
nucléaire contrairement à ce qu'on a dit
souvent dans la presse de manière un peu
hâtive
les Russes n'ont jamais vraiment
proférées de menaces nucléaire objectif
ça bruno-tertrée le territoire journal
on parle très bien
et pour l'instant la la grammaire de la
dissuasion nucléaire est respectée entre
les deux géants nucléaires ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut avoir
gardé à l'esprit pour l'instant il n'y a
pas eu de dérapages il y a pas eu de
changement les Russes n'ont pas
prononcé des mots qui seraient en
inadéquation avec leur doctrine donc on
reste en terrain connu et pour l'instant
il y a pas eu de dérapage oui il y a pas
de dérapage ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas un risque zéro et
notamment mais ça je pense que tous les
acteurs en ont conscience le risque
évident c'est si vraiment il y a un
effondrement militaire russe
là que fera venir Poutine c'est là où il
y a un danger mais c'est et donc j'ai
envie de dire le danger il est pas
tellement à court terme c'est que se
passe-t-il par exemple scénario les
330000 soldats mobilisés russes arrivent
ils ont déployés en Ukraine et malgré
tout
gigantesque défaite militaires russes là
quels sont les moyens conventionnels
c'est un non nucléaire de vladir Poutine
pour réagir pour changer la donne et
pour ne pas tout perdre
et c'est là je pense
scénario qui n'est absolument pas
certain mais qui est de l'ordre du
possible c'est ce jour là
où il faudra que on s'inquiète par
rapport à ça qu'on s'inquiète et espérer
que le que cette ce dialogue stratégique
en matière nucléaire entre les
États-Unis et la Russie
résiste est-ce qu'il y a plus de risques
on peut dire maintenant qui est qui a
trois quatre mois parce qu'on en parle
de plus en plus sur la sur le nucléaire
je dirais que le risque est le
le même il est il est extrêmement faible
il est extrêmement fan en tout cas c'est
ce que disent la plupart des experts sur
les questions nucléaires
il est peut-être un peu plus élevé
puisque il y a eu on en parle maintenant
déjà un début de défaite dans
stratégique pour les Russes forcément ça
veut dire les décideurs on a Florian
Richard qui nous demande qui nous parle
de la transmistrie est-ce qu'on a des
nouvelles parce qu'on en a parlé au
début du conflit mais aujourd'hui on ne
parle plus de cette région puisque il
sait plus du tout ah non mais c'est hors
de porter des Russes juste la
transistitrice et en rayer là en gris
c'est cette bande de terre de facto
indépendants qui fait partie
officiellement de la Moldavie donc qui
situe entre la Moldavie et l'Ukraine qui
est composé de prorus parce qu'en fait
elle a chute de l'Union soviétique les
gens transnistries avaient fait un
référendum qui a
d'autodéatermination il avait dit qu'il
voulait rester
enfin indépendant ça n'avait pas été
reconnu internationalement et depuis
c'est une forme de conflit gelé donc
depuis le début des années 90 vous avez
quelques centaines ou quelques milliers
je crois environ 2000 solarius qui sont
permanence déployer en transmistrer et
donc évidemment dans le grand projet
impérial russe
qui aurait enfin où l'invasion aurait
poussé vers l'ouest
jusqu'àodessa pour priver le l'Ukraine
d'accès à la mer dans ce scénario mais
qui n'est plus du tout d'actualité
évidemment les russes auraient relié la
transmission donc potentiellement le
conflit aurait débordé sur la Moldavie
alors on a deux questions concernant la
Biélorussie la biologie peut-être
peut-elle et surtout à tel les moyens
d'attaquer l'Ukraine avec les forces qui
ont été envoyées là-bas depuis quelques
semaines et la Russie était
militairement impliquée alors
on va vous montrer la carte quand même
aussi là parce que hop voilà il faut
qu'on trouve c'est au nord de de
l'Ukraine et je rappelle que au début de
l'invasion russe en février il y avait
une attaque par trois fronts par l'est
par le sud et par le nord et les Russes
étaient passés étaient passés par le
territoire biélorus pour attaquer Kiev
par le nord il y avait juste 150 km de
la frontière jusqu'à la capitale
ukrainienne mais il y avait pas eu de
déploiement de troupes biélorusses
aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas
euh rien n'indique pour l'instant
qu'il y en aura là encore la plupart des
spécialistes doutent plus pour plusieurs
raisons le régime de lucachenko qui a
été très difficilement élu enfin il a
pas été élu réellement c'était une
sélection
il y a 2 ans maintenant le régime est
extrêmement fragile il y avait eu des
manifestations qui avaient vraiment mis
en danger le système politique biélorus
et aujourd'hui Lucas and Co ne tient que
parce qu'il est soutenu et qu'il dépend
intégralement du Kremlin donc que ça
soit pour le cachenko ou pour Poutine
engager des troupes biélorusses en
Ukraine c'est prendre un risque
politique absolument considérable je
suis pas sûr que la Russie ait envie en
plus d'avoir à gérer une nouvelle crise
biélorus la deuxième chose c'est que la
Biélorussie c'est un petit pays au
nombre d'habitants c'est 9 millions si
je dis pas de bêtises
et c'est une petite armée c'est un pays
quand même assez pauvre
militairement ça vous probablement pas
grand chose et donc si vous voulez c'est
pas le déploiement de troupes biélorusse
qui vont inverser la donne militairement
sur le terrain
or ça serait un coup ça représenterait
un coup politique absolument
considérable donc à mon avis
déploiement direct de soldats biélorus
en Ukraine et peu probable en revanche
la biélorus et impliquée indirectement
de plusieurs manières déjà parce qu'il y
a des déploiements russes en Biélorussie
c'est toujours le cas notamment
plusieurs dizaines de milliers en tout
cas plusieurs milliers de mobiliser
russe qui vont s'entraîner en
Biélorussie et qui représente une forme
de menace c'est à dire que la Russie a
toujours les moyens si elle le veut
d'engager quelques milliers d'hommes ou
quelques dizaines de milliers d'hommes
pour ouvrir un nouveau front
au nord par exemple alors du coup ça
force les
Ukrainiens le prendre en compte et à
garder des réserves
pour cette éventualité ça n'est pas
réellement crédible parce que à quoi bon
envoyer 10000 hommes pour attaquer de
tcherny faut au nord-est de Kiev et les
Russes n'y arriveraient pas le jour où
les Russes auront 150000 l'homme massé à
la frontière biélorus là les Ukrainiens
seront obligés dans tenir compte
réellement mais les Russes n'ont pas les
moyens de faire ça donc ça ne se produit
pas ensuite les faut pas oublier aussi
que les Biélorusses ont des gros stocks
d'armes
issues de l'Union soviétique beaucoup de
chars beaucoup de blindés beaucoup de
camions etc probablement des stocks de
munitions et donc la Russie peut
s'appuyer sur Minsk pour augmenter son
stock et on sait qu'elle en a vraiment
besoin parce que c'est une guerre
dépression qui dure depuis huit mois et
que l'une des questions c'est qui
tiendra le plus longtemps en termes de
stock et troisièmement c'est un détail
mais ça dit quelque chose
il y a des
sont très forts
d'assemblage de drones iranien Shahid
en Biélorussie d'accord donc en fait il
serait assemblé là-bas avant d'être
envoyé pas tous mais ça serait une
localisation voilà on parlait tout faire
des des négociations puisque on entre
midi on entend de plus en plus il y a un
G20 qui est prévu à Bali Poutine a dit
qu'il ne se rendra pas est-ce que
Poutine est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'il y a
quand même des chefs d'État côté
occidentaux on va dire qui qui essaye
encore de discuter avec lui
oui absolument et alors pas de peut-être
pas directement alors il y avait Macron
qui est adorait faire ça mais ce qui
était plutôt pas forcément une nouvelle
chose à partir d'une bonne volonté mais
mais le problème c'est que de toute
manière de depuis qu'il a révélé
publiquement les échanges qui l'a vu
avec vladim Vladimir Poutine lors d'un
échange justement téléphonique
les Russes ne veulent plus trop en
entendre parler
néanmoins on voit c'est le plus
important qu'il y a toujours des
échanges
à des niveaux plus discrets on va dire
entre les Occidentaux et les Russes là
on a vu récemment on a appris par le
Washington Post oui je crois c'est sa
wash il donne post que Sullivan qui est
le conseiller la sécurité nationale
américain
avait eu des contacts avec des
responsables de Oran
en Russie ces dernières semaines
probablement pour parler de
nucléaire peut être aussi pour parler de
Carson parce que le voilà et
donc oui il y a toujours des contacts et
c'est plutôt une très bonne chose
serait la ligne rouge pour le Kremlin
comme par le Lignon rouge parce qu'on
parle nucléaire
rouge et qu'on s'est rarement où on
annonce rarement où elle est parce que
sinon il suffit de taper juste en
dessous de la ligne rouge et c'est ce
qui s'est passé au début de la gare
d'ailleurs parce que
l'Ukraine n'est pas la ligne rouge pour
les États-Unis et voilà il avait bien
compris mais c'est pas le premier
président américain en fait cette erreur
enfin
Obama avait fait cette erreur de dire
très clairement qui a été la ligne rouge
en Syrie sur les armes chimiques
les les Syriens on avait utilisé et donc
ça va être décrédibiliser Obama qui du
coup était obligé d'intervenir et qui
est au dernier moment avait refusé
abstenu et du coup ça décrédibilise la
parole d'où le fait que sur toutes ces
questions
stratégiques de ligne rouge d'intérêt
fondamentaux etc
il y a par définition une ambiguïté
qu'on appelle qu'on qualifie une
stratégique
précisément pour empêcher
l'adversaire de jouer avec Céline rouge
donc je suis incapable de dire si la
Crimée est une ligne rouge notamment sur
le plan nucléaire
malgré tout on sait que c'est quelque
chose qui serait absolument primordial
pour la Russie beaucoup plus que le
Dombas ça n'aurait rien à voir pour
plein de raisons mais notamment
la principale c'est que
quasiment la Russie perdrait son accès à
la mer Noire donc si vous voulez ça
serait absolument historique pour la
Russie
l'histoire de la Russie c'est dernier
siècles
c'est l'histoire d'une poussée pour
avoir un accès vers les mers chaudes ce
thème est même dans l'hymne russe et
donc s'il perdent la Crimée si il
perdent la base navale de Sébastopol ils
perdent leur accès à la mer Noire de
facto
et donc l'accès indirect à la
Méditerranée et donc elle aussi en
mondial par le sud c'est pour les Russes
ça serait une catastrophe géopolitique
à mon avis insupportable
je ne sais pas où ça amènerait on peut
pas savoir mais mais c'est l'une des
raisons je pense pour lesquelles
à un moment
les motivations des Occidentaux et les
motivations des Ukrainiens pourraient
diverger et on a une question justement
sur la flotte russe depuis le masque va
est-ce que la flotte russe sort encore
de ses bases et en fait est-ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle est utile finalement à la
Russie dans la mer Noire alors c'est
très intéressant oui à la elle a une
utilité notamment c'est que les navires
russes ou les sous-marins russes servent
de base de lancement aux missiles de
croisière caliba et pour plein de
raisons de de traiter j'ai pas rentrer
dans les détails mais enfin bref les
fautes dire que les missiles de
croisière tiraient depuis la mer ou une
portée supérieure au missile de
croisière tirée depuis la Terre et donc
c'est l'outil principal qui permet
à la Russie de frapper l'intégralité du
territoire
ukrainien c'est lié au traité
inef pour le dire vite un missile
calibre à 2500 km de portée un missile
islandeur donc une missile semi
balistique terrestre
ça à peu près 500 km de portée
donc pour les Russes c'est extrêmement
important par ailleurs la la flotte sert
toujours à contrôler à exercer une forme
de blocus
alors il y a eu un accord notamment
céréalier mais disons que les Russes
sont toujours les moyens
tout bloqués de tout bloquer s'il le
souhaite ce qu'il y a en revanche c'est
qu'il y a une vulnérabilité de la flotte
russe en mer Noire qui avait terminé
complètement sous-estimé par les Russes
qui pensait un peu qui était dans un une
sorte de que la mer Noire est un lagrus
ça n'est absolument pas le cas pour
plein de raisons alors on avait vu avec
le la question des missiles un missile
anti navire tirait depuis la depuis la
terre des mucils Ukrainiens dans le
cadre du enfin ex soviétique dans le
cadre de Luc de du muscva c'était ici
Neptune ensuite on a vu
des missiles américain je ne sais pas si
c'était des stocks américains enfin en
tout cas des missiles de fabrication
américaine Harpoon qui sont des missiles
ont-ils navires et là encore on parle de
300 km de portée donc depuis des saints
on est quasiment on va quasiment jusqu'à
Sébastien donc ça c'est une menace
terrible pour les Russes et on a vu
récemment
qu'il y a une attaque de drone sur la
flotte russe et qui était dans sa base à
Sébastopol là je voudrais bien revenir
quelques secondes là-dessus parce que on
a dit beaucoup de choses et finalement
on avait peu d'éléments factuels
il semblerait que donc c'est une attaque
avec des drones navals c'est-à-dire des
des navires autonomes tout petits
qui frôle
qui sont à peine au-dessus de la surface
quasiment des semis supers merci et qui
ensuite vont
s'exploser sur sur une cible par exemple
ils ont gorgés de bourré d'explosifs et
on a parlé de de jet ski démonté qui ont
été envoyés peut-être les dessins que
j'ai parce qu'en fait les les Russes
avaient capturé certains de ces mois un
qui avait été montré
ça pas tout à fait la forme
d'un jet-ski une sorte de une sorte de
barque assez aérodynamique mais après je
j'ai pas les plans donc
à quoi ça ressemble mais donc il y a une
attaque par des drones navales et des
drones aériens je sais pas lesquels
peut-être des drones suicide ou
et tout ça probablement piloté aussi
grâce à des avions espions
occidentaux les satellites de meuf etc
donc une attaque vraiment non vergure
alors sauf que quand sur le moment on a
eu l'impression notamment que la frégate
amiral macarov avait été
au moins touché
parce que le enfin il y avait une vidéo
notamment qui le suggérait on voyait le
drone qui qui fonçait vers la frégate
et donc là ça aurait été un énorme
retentissement parce que déjà le mozzle
est beaucoup parlé c'était un très gros
bateau mais c'était très vieux et d'un
peu d'humidité il savait plus à rien la
frégate macarov elle est elle est très
récente elle porte ses missiles et en
réalité les Russes n'ont pas tant que ça
des missiles qui portent des calibres et
puis par ailleurs c'est le navire amiral
de la flotte de russe puisqu'il a
remplacé le mustva qui aujourd'hui au
fin fond de la mer Noire donc ça aurait
été le fait de taper le meufva ça aurait
été un vrai coup là il semblerait
finalement
parce qu'il y a que deux frégats de ce
type actuellement en mer Noire on les a
vu il y a des photos satellites POS
attaque dans le port donc en tout cas
ils n'ont pas été coulés il ne semble
pas qu'il y ait d'énormes dégâts il y a
peut-être des dégâts mais ils semblent
pas aussi important aussi important
qu'on pouvait le penser donc le résultat
final de cette attaque n'est pas
considérable malgré tout ça ça illustre
encore une fois cette vulnérabilité
russe mais qui se voit à peu près à tous
les étages c'est-à-dire ça se voit pour
la flotte ça se voit pour les avions
c'est absolument incroyable mais la
flotte aérienne russe
n'est quasiment pas enfin et peut
utiliser ou en tout cas rarement loin
des lignes
parce que
ils n'ont pas de domination complète du
ciel aérien ce qui peut paraître
complètement délirant alors même que
l'Ukraine n'a quasiment plus de chasse
que que l'armée russe a quand même une
très grosse
Armée de l'Air ça paraît très étonnant
et puis on sait ce qu'il en est de
l'armée donc il y a une vulnérabilité
russe qui est encore une fois saute aux
yeux alors on a cellier qui nous
donnerait alors non c'était pas c'est la
Christophe de Marc si le dirige mais
c'est une réponse une question à
laquelle vous n'avez pas avoir de
réponse je vous préviens Christophe
qui refuse tous sessions de son
territoire combien de temps avant la fin
du conflit alors là
je répondrai pas cette question on
répondra pas à cette question
ben voilà je pense qu'on a fait un peu
le tour de toutes les questions je
regarde les derniers mais non je pense
que nous ça nous sommes bien on nous a
ça fait une heure que nous discutons
avec vous tout de même quand même voilà
comme d'habitude vous êtes très nombreux
à nous suivre merci en tout cas d'avoir
été très nombreux merci Alexis pour
remercier
énormément précographie
qui fait donc toutes ces cartes bien sûr
que vous pouvez retrouver sur le site du
Figaro voilà ces deux cartes s'écartent
très précises en plus de la zone de Cars
[Musique]
très voilà même on fait des cartes pas
que très général de sur des sur des
petites zones Merci beaucoup à eux
effectivement d'avoir été de nous avoir
fourni ces cartes merci une nouvelle
fois Alexis et moi je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux live sur fear live